jean-paul j'ai dit que tu étais mon
copain parce que j'ai vu que tout à
l'heure tu savais faire des grimaces ou
ce oui est ce que tu veux me faire
quelques grimaces
je vais essayer de refaire la même
tu me diras si c'est bien non on va
faire un concours de grimaces tous les
deux et c'est le réalisateur qui juge à
toi de commencer vas-y moi j'en fais une
autre comment tu la trouves manche
maghribia c'est moche c'est mieux d'y et
toi ma jean-paul devant l'aude
je vais essayer de la fin comment tu
trouves
aurélie notre avant dernière candidate
qui a beaucoup de mal à descendre jeter
dans une diatribe allemand
0e au bras et au la simone kuhn à main
elle avait une bise à l'autre
pourquoi tu embrasses et le petit garçon
capitale où étais tu viens mona un qui
dit moi voilà état qu'est ce que tu veux
vient de s'agrandir
bah oui
et c'est tout le jeu passe vous avez
vous une oreille alors qu'elle chante
une charte là allez donnez moi la
première donne quoi
sauvé
on l'applaudît thème bien manger
qu'est ce que tu aimes le mieux le tapis
alors oui surtout passer l'orage live
inédite pour la nuit veut il fait figure
la nuit 10 capsules et tu fais la nuit
mais c'est à vous
pourquoi ça c'est marrant c'est pour ça
que j'aime bien jouer parce que ça fait
péter oui j'y pense quand même et ça
c'est marrant oui ya que toi qui ça
arrive dans la famille ya que toi qui ça
arrive dans la famille
la pièce qui pète encore à l'école je
mange à la cantine où tu mens c'est
maman et moi vous qu'elle est intime et
il mange un petit peu chez mama et à la
cantine qu'est ce qu'on mange
et injure à nos besoins du cassoulet à
l'aîné
mademoiselle amandine donnez moi la main
et je vous accompagne dans du tout il
vaut 1 nicolas il évoquera la famille
s'ils s'étaient grandement la rupture ne
m et j'étais un papy que c'est comme les
bains il retient ses pairs
alors que vivant oui les abats vos
repères
oui ils peuvent que des filles johnny on
ou pas
on l'applaudît samedi du monde bien
battus 9 9 bis comment tu le trouve bon
marierait l'équipe
j'ai déjà amoureuse de lui
il ya longtemps depuis combien de temps
bien heureuse de pierre bachelet
tu as écrit d'amour il n'a jamais
répondu parce qu'on a vu que ça j'ai un
camp mais je veux te voir avec avec avec
sens tout à leurs pantins un an et demi
maintenant vous avez fait connaissance
voilà oui pourquoi t'en rends tu peux
avoir la patience d'attendre attendre
qu'est ce que tu me chantait 110 pour
toi lamoureux a compris ça veut dire
il doit me dis moi demain
c'est un noeud
potel
non
oui
est ce que tu me dois chanter avec son
amoureux pas tout de suite il faut
attendre quelques années encore
qu'est-ce qui veut pas pas comme métier
où il est allé rouleur et maman risque
élevé oui mais si la machine papa et
rouleur et la machine à quoi la machine
pourra pas y en a qui a conduit au moins
tu es tout seul tu as des petits frères
des petites soeurs
trois copains elle file
il s'est défait de deux heures non même
pas
et pourquoi tu en veux pas parce que
t'es pas déjà parent
notre dernier candidat yoran bien
violent 800 dépendants ont reçu des
électriciens et les moustaches du don et
la bande moustache j'ai vu elle est
cassée et moustache on ne voulait pas
qu'on sache que je porte des lunettes
alors elle les a enlevées voilà pour les
remettre maintenant un album il y met
d'habitude il a les avaient enlevés pour
pas qu'on voit qu'il tentait lunettes il
est drôlement gentille maman comment
c'est son petit nom vengeance il vient
n'est pas pas commencé son plein champ
vol il a une bonne bouille jean-paul il
boit de l'eau du vin j'en étais sûr
c'est un copain à moi combien il boit
par jour 2 3 2 3
3les par jour autant du deux flots dit
toi tu vois pas demain tu vois du sirop
maman bois du l'un d'eux
c'est le petit philippe qui arrive et on
l'applaudît très fort
on a failli tomber dix ans qu'est ce que
tu vas chanter
à ses parents mais non c'est pas grave
mon pantalon rouille qui un elfe attaque
où tu ne vois pas sur mes chaussures
kiejman outils comme ça oui ça se voit
pas du tout cas fait pipi
puis tu sais les chaussures ça va cesser
n'a pas ses choix pas et des chaussures
en bois c'est des chaussures au japon
oui enfin ça va tu as fais pipi
maintenant tu es tranquille qui alors
qu'est ce que tu chantes
qu'est ce que tu veux un qi et ben vas-y
il chante
les militants vatican coeur comme chef
japonais dans l'écran
mon premier candidat joris allait
bientôt ce qu'est ce que tu vas chanter
jose
on s'embrasse on oublie tout j'ai dû me
tiens allez moi la noce week-end ouais
frédéric soit attentif
son caractère
tu plan parce que tu es content et
heureux et moi sourit
l'autre
candidat qui qui ne me fera pas de
cadeau c'est christian maxime un
personnage haut en couleur ça va
christian on t'appelle christian on
t'appelle maxime qui qui savent à qui tu
es venu avec qui le suisse il est papa
ah bon tu es vu avec lui il est pas là
pas voulu montrer sa grande tête à la
télé qu'est-ce qui fait comme métier
papa
mais se crache pas dessus
je me force à l'orge postillonne des
bois qu'est ce que tu vas chanter quatre
ans on le croit
nana mouskouri elle chante cette chanson
ah bon parce que fais tu aimes les
chansons de même mouskouri tu aimes par
les changements de nanas et comment tu
la trouves pas
tu as eu ton paquet
moi je vais cracher dessus et wade bosh
enfin le moment
puis aux antilles un papa est à
travailler ici à ton papa c d e
bah ça c'est la première fois que je
vois un papa qui fait d eux ça c'est
formidable
ou bien on emmenait au vétérinaire vu
qu'il y avait un chat y avait il y avait
griffé la sasp est infecté papa fileront
voirie pensons bissau les pires sur le
chien
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ton papa il répare
d'une cuillère dans la bouche qui va
dans le ventre il évite pas que ce que
serge wibaut m'a ébahi rage les pots de
vin
vous êtes rangel a beaucoup de chance
j'ai compris tu voyais dans un hôpital à
vous occuper des malades alors lui bah
il dit la vérité c'est vrai vous faites
tout ce qui est le plus difficile à
faire vous occuper des eaux vives pau et
les maires n'ont pas pas toujours tout à
fait plus tô t elle ma tête dit des
bêtises mais pas l'air si tu disais dbt
il est aujourd'hui dont abbott un bon
je vais chanter tous les enfants sont
avec moi toi et là le discours est bien
aussi tu la vois la télévision mireille
mathieu masseau va pas souvent et les
jolies oui marierait bien avec elle ah
oui famille
pourquoi suis-je et même coup alors à
lui verra bisous salem trop attention à
rester sérieux attendait les fiançailles
alors qu'est-ce que tu touches ans
nicolas tout cas
en maths aujourd'hui quand on parle est
un parent on faisait jeter à l'eau de
ces 3
ma troisième candidate et l'élégance en
personne c'est marie des biens publics
ici mon papa m'aime bien sûr mais
permettez que je fasse connaissance de
la famille
c'est ambiance et c'est ton fiancé
alors pour vous embrasser pourquoi et
comment tu commences à ses parents il
est trop sympathique
oui la belle mère est gentil très
bientôt des belles mamans reprenait dont
le mari
m
monsieur christophe pour la plongée très
fort alors tu viens là christophe quel
âge tu as aussi longtemps que je fais ça
fout le micro à 6 ans voilà c'est bien
ça va la bonne hauteur la fia l'essai
avait laissé là d'un dire à un homme
politique
est-ce que tu regarde la télévision se
revend items bien regarder la télé alors
qu'est ce que tu en penses tous ces
hommes politiques qui n'arrête pas de
parler tu sais faire les pépés dumont
pète c'est moi voir comment ils font
attendu avec moi un gros plan sur son
nom d'artiste la vote moi voilà est-ce
que tu veux me refaire le ppd moi parce
que moi j'y prends à part du masi a vu
l'appel full web un peu mais toi tu est
chose a le moins qu'à croquer tendance à
800 soit je garde encore moi pas tu as
toi quand on se mit à noisy le sec mais
déjà pas mal de 7
alors maintenant attention c'est
certainement le plus grand la haye à
n'en pas douter c'est l'aîné oulala
qu'il est grand aulaqi l'écran ou qu'il
est grand c'est eric au quilit grand
éric on applaudit eric
qu'elle a su à eric c'est quand combien
fait quand on peint 10 dont 5 ans ou
assez facile étonnant alors qu'est-ce
que tu es grand pour cinq ans je vais
voir ton papa s'il est aussi grand will
hayes a présidé au ton papa est plus
petit toit tourner les tout petits il
est très grand combien il mesure 5
mètres et un monsieur vous devez avoir
du mal à vous habiller en confection ton
papa mesure 5 mètres et dammam en six
mètres
et bien dites moins chère madame voilà
une grande famille et leur dit bonjour
et tu as un frère tu es tu n'as pas de
frère pas de ça vous êtes une grande tué
un chien les combinés mesure
est ce que c'est la première fois que tu
rencontres nana mouskouri et que tu la
vois pour de vrai et à ton avis combien
les mesures
notre troisième candidate mademoiselle
sylvie que jouer demande d'applaudir
bien fort bienvenu et l'heure tu es venu
tout seul où tu es venu avec ta famille
dis moi ta famille qui sait alors oui
santé par an et comment il s'appelle
papa a dit freddy je le connais je les
dis qu'est-ce qui fait comme métier
voilà mes filles est il normal de 3h10
ou ici d'un fan
ah oui les gens aiment que le dit
oui oui eux aussi les grammages à damery
mac os x factor
ils boivent dépeinte à la gendarmerie le
blizzard à ses débuts
la litanie de la joie bien
lewin est finie
près de dix ans durant lequel one you
were the big man mois métier tu veux
faire un bon ni oiseau ou et ben oui je
me demande t on d'un toit à bittou à
pantin
comment ces bandes joue mes jolies
cartes par et ben voila si veut traduire
à présent la guerre
ligue 1
je le redis feu
non
un signe
jean reno
je voulais voir chez cooler
et gilles babycare
les mois
mes jambes
suivis d'explosions
m
gaillon
et mon sourire
m
je l'avais connu des yeux
déjà
jeu politicien
nous
produite
je les payais jamais
voir
s'arranger sur ma
bourdin est où maintenant quand j'étais
chanteur
bon mes gardes
monsieur malik on l'applaudît
malik
tadjau lisieux oui c'est les yeux ta
maman les yeux tomba pas des milliers de
sacs la papa la rhune très hâte beau
film d'horreur locker dollar et valait
une petite fille après après laver il
avait misé à fond d'elle qu'à part les
pays là tu as eu peur n'avait pas eu
peur parce que j'aime bien les films
d'horreur ont fermé la porte
c'est bien ça beau film on peut
l'applaudir
l'araignée à la fin
comment ça se passe et si la tue
l'araignée
et nous allons accueillir cette
ravissante vanessa regarde comme elle
est jolie fait une grosse bise à
philippe là et vous applaudissez très
fort je m'appelle et me dit je m'appelle
et me dit
j'ai joué des parties
et nous ferons du elle germé et je
voudrais vivre les goûts
ma vie
tu t'appelles emilie jolie
lucas pellet
jalili
tout est parti
tout est toujours été réglo paris
bon vraiment y chante si bien voir tout
ce que vous lisez
l'auteur est champion on disait cette
petite histoire très très très juste
bien tout d'abord je vais la chercher
parce que j'ai peur quand même qu'elles
tombent les escales ils ont plus grand
qu'elle marlène et bien marley
on applaudit marley qu'est ce que tu vas
nous chanter c'est vous avez c'est beau
la vie
c'est la première fois que tu vois
patrick juvet comment tu le trouves
quand tu le trouves il était elle te
prouve à billets alors vas-y
c'est beau la vie allez-y doucement 1-1
2-3
aimant il s'agit
et vous dites que de l'amitié
qui dit
pis
paul gillet
alexandra tu l'as eu 1 500 j'avais deux
rêves de titre mais j'aimerais tout de
suite voilà ce bonbon pour la semaine
prochaine
oui il ya plus de goutte qui tombe bien
un litige
avec qui tu es venu pour la maman le
papa est dit est dit famille j'aimerais
voir papa alors les gouttes
qu'est-ce qui fait papa comme métier il
écoute
n'étant pas
nous usons mai
c'est johan le premier candidat noir
il ya du bon ben oui quand tu les
trouves les noms de personnes n'ont pas
bien bay on lit pas bien ça c'est ce que
je vais vous trouvez il vous trouve
moches
thème mieux les enfants
oui pourquoi qu'est ce que tu reproches
aux grandes personnes
3e et à un épuisement
par une saison droit mallet vieille
droite a même ma bab mon ami très viril
là bas
à hong kong
pour progrès y attendiez mama mama reste
pas de prix
étudier avec qui mon papa et ma patte a
tout à y gagner
et ma vie devenir maintenant
vous m'appelez est là pour longtemps
qu'est ce que tu sais faire dans une
école maternelle ça tu peux m'aider la
dalle est un peu mais dit julien peuvent
aider vous va bien sûr comment tu
t'appelles nicolas facile à temps alors
qu'il finit je finis avec avec geoffrey
et tu restes là tu vas bd1 tu avais dit
que tu m'aiderait oui alors c'est toi
qui devrait poser les questions à ma
place c'est vrai qu'est ce que tu
voudras faire quand tu sauras vésinet
c'est très bien
tu fais soigner les animaux oui ça bien
stéphanie glina bonnet bien fort bien
rester polis tu viens de 7 mais c'est un
pays que j'adore et avec eux qui devenu
papa maman et moi
les mamans travaillent et l'hélicidine
effet à prix modique qui vous fait le
mien mais comme un pape accouché d'un
motif était nuit pas pas couché dans son
lit cette nuit oui et moi j'ai couché
dans l'élite et ma maman à est ce que tu
vas à l'église jamais appris hier petit
jésus je vous donne mon coeur
j'ai pas qui c'est le petit jésus il
habite pas cet âge ils habitent 7
mais je ne peux pas m
m
johan sarah-jane ça vient j'ai tout de
suite vu que c'était un garçon qu'elle a
su agen quatre mois dit non et puis je
vais te dire j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
vend des gros bras comme ça tu fais du
sport toi qu'est ce tu fais quand le
sport
savoir comment tu en fais trop fait voir
aux phillies juste juste au choix alors
qu'est ce que t'es fort ça va
relativement c'est la même langue
c'est ton petit-frère cadeaux et alors
est ce que tu le bosc est lui aussi ses
mosquées ya alors s'évade il gagne assez
formidable viens voir page 20 janvier
les deux parties bien baveux qu'est ce
que tu as une seconde qua non vous
n'allez pas poster leurs stocks break il
dit long quel beau score mme alliot jus
à la baisse que tu veux
qu'est ce que tu chantes comme j'en sors
assez fort il y avait ça on va l'écouter
mais
tout près
dunoyer
sean garrett un traître mot
prévoir phase i 1 2 3 ou la foule ah oui
ben vous comprendrez six ans donc on est
ici sans aller bien
vas-y alexandre 1 2 3
te dire hé ben ali daei la casse tenir
un est-ce que tu suces ton pouce
alexandre s'est promis ça t'a jamais su
si ton pouce si mais quand toute la nuit
ouais de voir comment tu fais
assez drôle ça c'est pas ton pouce que
tu suis assez les deux doigts du milieu
fait pas sa première fois je vois ça tu
sais sifflé tu peux me siffler cul oui
voilà un garçon complètement complet
alors qu'elle est le repo celle où sont
tes parents c'est ce qu'il aime le doigt
qu attend mais à quoi il ressemble il
ressemble à rien très bien qu est ce que
tu nous chante trop grands maintenant et
pas facile trop grands maintenant donc
aux besoins passé 10 mois deux ans avec
la neige on vise deux jambes comme
étrange qui venait de couper l'eau la
moitié de la musique
alors quand tu seras grande toi est ce
que tu as déjà choisi un métier lequel
un coup qu'est ce que tu veux tu seras
grand baptiste quentin n'y a pas dr mais
aux pattes
qu'est ce qui t'attire le métier de
doctor p 10
je veux devenir docteur ya du pognon et
on voit des femmes avoir un deux heures
cascadeur boxeur karaté judo cowboys
n'ont vainqueur du coup ma faim poids se
ramasser les vedettes de la chanson ou
du cinéma et qui venaient de tous très
bien qu est ce que tu veux servir tout
ça drôle
attends là largement à quelques
explications